[Music]
it is the best-selling book in history
no volume ever written has been more
loved and quoted and its words sometimes
simple and sometimes mysterious should
always be studied carefully it is the
bible the word of god welcome to bible
answers live providing accurate and
practical answers to all your bible
questions
our phone lines are open if you have a
bible related question give us a call
now at 800 god says that's 800-463-7297
now here's your host from amazing facts
international pastor doug batchelor
hello friends would you like to hear an
amazing fact
only 1 in 10 000 diamonds found are
colored
and only one in every 100 diamonds is
greater than 10 carats in size
furthermore
only one out of 200 diamonds is flawless
so you can imagine the worldwide
astonishment when miners in angola
africa discovered a 170 carat flawless
pink diamond in july 2022
named the lulu rose after the mine where
it was discovered the 34 gram rock is
believed to be the largest pink diamond
discovered in the last 300 years
the former record holder is a hundred
and eighty-two carat dairy noor found in
india in the 17th century and it now
resides in the national bank of tehran
it's hard to say what this diamond will
sell for after its cut but just for
comparison the pink star diamond
shattered every price record when south
beast sold it in april 2017 for a
staggering 71.2 million at a hong kong
auction
it was the single most expensive diamond
or jewel sold at an auction and catch
this it took professionals more than a
year and a half just to cut and polish
this pink star
now the pink star was 59.60 carats it's
anyone's guess what the 170 carat lulu
rose will sell for
you know pastor ross it's amazing how
much a rock
will sell for i know i'm going to get
something that rare that strong so
beautiful apparently flawless i mean
that's an incredible find one wonders
how many diamonds of that quality is
still out there buried under the ground
that nobody knows about but you know
talking about valuable rocks probably
the most valuable rock is not diamond or
some type of emerald
it's written on stone
and it's put in a golden box and it's
hidden away for many many many years of
course what we're talking about is the
ten commandments the most precious rocks
not because of the rock per se but
because of what's written on the rock
that's right you know i kind of like
rocks yeah i lived in a cave and we were
surrounded by rocks and you actually get
to know some of them and their shapes
and their their design and colors and
christ is often compared to a rock in
the bible he said his word he said he
that hears these words of mine and does
them is like a wise man building on the
rock
and you can read in ephesians 2 19-22
now therefore you are no more strangers
and foreigners but fellow citizens with
the saints and of the household of god
and are built on the foundation of the
apostles and prophets
jesus christ himself being the chief
corner stone
in whom all the building fitly framed
together grows into a holy temple in the
lord in whom you are builded together
for a habitation of god through the
spirit and peter says we are lively
stones built on that cornerstone of
jesus who is the rock of ages and that's
you know rocks in the bible represents
something enduring
and perfect if you're going to
want something to last like the pyramids
or even a tombstone
you make it out of stone it so it'll
last and that's why god wrote his law on
rock because of its enduring nature
he wrote it with his own hand because
his law doesn't change that's right
people's opinions come and go but the
word of god endures forever you might
want to know more about this very
special law written on stone there in
that golden box you don't have to go
find the golden box to read what's
written on the stone it's in the bible
it's the ten commandments we have a book
it's actually one of our study guides
called written in stone and it's all
about the ten commandments and the
principles that we find in scripture in
that law if you'd like to receive this
free gift all you need to do is call the
number 800-835-6747
and you want to ask for offer number 111
or ask by name written in stone and
we'll be happy to send that to anyone
here in north america if you're outside
of north america just go to the amazing
facts website just amazingfacts.org
or
dot com and you'll be able to read that
study guide right there online we're
also going to give you a few other
numbers as we work our way through the
program but if you have a bible related
question the number to call here to the
studio is
four 800-463-7297
three seven two nine seven and also if
you would like to email us a bible
question you can do so at bal questions
at amazingfacts.org
bal questions amazingfacts.org
pass it out before we get too far into
the program we want to welcome some new
uh radio stations that are carrying this
program alive we want to greet those who
are listening in jacksonville florida
on the truth stations that's 91.7 fm in
florida 91.9 fm
and also those listening in georgia 91.3
fm so if you're in the area in
jacksonville
give us a call we'd love to hear from
you this evening
i'll pass it out before we go to the
phone lines as we always do we'd like to
start with prayer dear father we thank
you for this time that we have to be
able to open your word and study and we
always ask for the spirit to come and
guide us here in the studio and be with
those who are listening wherever they
might be and lord lead us into a clearer
understanding of what the bible teaches
before we ask this in jesus name amen
amen well i think we're ready for our
first call of this evening we've got uh
adrian listening from texas adrian
welcome to the program
hi how's it going good appreciate your
calling
yeah it's uh it's surreal to be talking
to you guys been watching out for a
while
well thank you and how can we help you
tonight what's the question
okay so basically the question um is how
do we reconcile
uh first corinthians 1
when paul is talking about
um that anything
meats and stuff that are sacrificed to
idols basically means nothing
and then jesus in revelation 2
verse 14
he's
saying that
he's actually admonishing the church
for eating meat sacrificed to idols so i
was just wondering how
we can reconcile those two things
yeah well i think they're talking about
two different things
um first of all revelation is full of
symbolism
and in revelation chapter two when he's
talking about balaam
well he's clearly not talking about
literal balaam who had been dead for
1400 years at that point
and later he talks about jezebel he
talks about these old testament
characters because of what they
represent
and the idea of eating something
sacrificed to idols
it was probably also talking about
eating those things that are unclean
which daniel would not do
that were sacrificed to idols daniel
would not be defiled because he wanted
to be faithful paul was dealing with a
different issue there were
jewish believers
that did not think that the gentiles
should eat any meat clean or unclean
sold in the roman the greco-roman market
places because whenever they butchered
anything it was butchered in front of a
an idol and so paul is saying look
the idol is nothing it's nothing wrong
with eating clean meat
and so
i wouldn't worry about that if your
conscience bothers you he says in romans
14 if you're not going to eat it don't
eat it
so
they're dealing with a different issue
there than what you see in revelation
and
eating things sacrificed to idols
in revelation is really talking about
ingesting false teachings that are
contaminated by paganism so there's a
whole spiritual overtone in revelation
that you don't have there in first
corinthians
all right thank you good question adrian
we've got james listening in illinois
james welcome to the program
thank you hi pastors may god continue to
bless you both for all that you do thank
you
my question is do we know the original
language was it hebrew or aramaic before
the tower of babel
no i you know i think everyone can
speculate but i don't think so
my guess is
that when we get to heaven if we're you
know we are still speaking the language
of canaan or eden
that we will find out that there are
certain words in many languages that can
be traced back
to the original language
people that study languages today
already see around the world as people
have migrated they've taken certain
words with them
i remember living among the navajo
indians for about a year and a half in
new mexico
and there was a tribe of
eskimos
in
alaska
that spoke almost identical language
they could understand each other but all
the tribes in between could not
understand each other
so you know it's obviously there's some
migration and languages change i mean
you look at american english compared to
england english compared to south
african english which pastor ross speaks
compared to australian english and you
can see that how quickly languages adopt
new words and
although if you had to guess pastor i
don't know what do you think do you
think maybe the descendants of seth that
stayed probably closer to noah after you
know they left the ark
um
spoke a language closer to the language
that was spoken before the flood versus
those who joined in the tower of babel
had their languages confused and then
dispersed around the globe you know we
don't know as you see yeah whatever that
language is it's changed a lot over time
say something in one language say
something in afrikaans in afrikaans
okay anyway that was worth it no i think
people want to know
for what it's worth i think some people
understood that
so yeah just it's amazing how languages
change over time
but um yeah so we don't know i think
pastor ross is right we might find that
some of the semitic languages um
that you're gonna find the language of
eden had a lot of similarity thanks for
that appreciate it thank you james we've
got next colleagues daryl listening in
florida daryl welcome to the program
hi pastors
my question
is regarding revelation chapter 13 verse
17 and
i just want to know uh why does it say
that no one can buy or sell unless they
have either
the mark of the beast which i know that
is like if you're
following the
the sunday law that's passed
obeying the sunday law or the name of
the beast which is vicarous feli di or
vicar of the son of god or
the number of his name which we all know
is 666. so why is it this or this or
this it's like
cash or check or credit card
like why why is it like that
well um
my guess is that here in in revelation
13 he's really saying anyone who
worships the beast and there's several
ways that that might be tested but it's
all going to boil down to the same thing
when you get to chapter 14 and uh i
think it's mentioned again in chapter 18
it just summarizes it by saying those
who worship the beast in his image
and so there will be different criteria
where you'll prove it
you know i know that like during world
war ii
uh there were laws made to basically
eradicate the jewish people
and there were one of several ways they
would identify them
it didn't have to be any one way but
they had a few different tests and so i
think it's saying here in revelation
there's a few different ways that your
worship of the beast will be measured
the buying and selling will be for
everybody if they don't cooperate
they'll be economic sanctions on
everybody who does not cooperate and
worship the beast
and at the end of time there's just two
groups those who have the mark of the
beast and those have the seal of god and
i think the reason it's mentioned here
the mark the name the number
it's just reaffirming what this power is
there'll be many that'll go along with
these laws that have to do with worship
or restricting worship because they want
to be able to buy and sell they don't
necessarily believe that this is what
the world needs there'll be those who
really believe that this is what the
world needs and be very supportive of it
but i think the vast majority will just
go along so that they can buy and sell
and so these there's different
motivations why people will do this but
it's emphasizing this power that's
described you know we do have a study
guide called the mark of the beast and
it talks about the subject and we'll be
happy to send that to anyone who calls
and asks the number to call for that is
800-835-6747
and you can ask for the study guide it's
called the mark of the beast and we'll
be happy to get that in the mail to
anyone here in north america
all right next quarter that we have is
joel listening in north carolina joel
welcome to the program
good evening everybody um pastor doug i
think i heard this in your sermons and
if i didn't if you didn't say this
please tell me so i can be corrected
but i'm trying to figure out why we as
christianity as a whole
separate tries to separate christianity
from
uh the jewish heritage
because i think it was you that said you
know we read a jewish book
we worship a jewish savior and when we
become a christian
we become spiritual jews yeah i said
that word for word
so that
i don't understand why christians try to
separate you know like they don't want
to
yeah well let me give you a few thoughts
on that first of all if um if a person
accepts christ
there is a difference between a
christian of course a christian except
except jesus as the messiah there are a
lot of jews so a christian can't just
say well i'm now a jew i tell my jewish
family he said now i'm a completed jew
because you know the jews were supposed
to both embrace and proclaim the messiah
um but uh and and so i think that we
should embrace the jewish heritage of uh
the christian church
uh way back in uh oh about
70 80 a.d after the jews had rebelled
against the romans and judaism
that you know was
basically frowned on
and
they were very upset with the jewish
nation for its rebellion against rome
there's a lot of anti-jewish sentiment
in the roman empire and so the
christians began to distance themselves
a little bit from the jews because the
persecution of the jews began to overlap
and they were persecuting christians
they said well these are these are jews
they worship the sabbath and
and they keep the same laws as the jews
and
and they begin to distance themselves
and so you know that trend has continued
through history it's just mind-boggling
that during world war ii
that you had
some nazis still considered themselves
christians
while they were exterminating jews
and if you've ever read the book the
hiding place
this one man who is
mr tin boom who was hiding jews in his
house he had a jewish baby and they said
if you have that jewish baby and you're
caught they'll kill you
he said it was a jewish baby that died
for me
and so he said i'm willing to and he did
end up dying
but you know they had the right attitude
anyway we have a book on that that's
called um spiritual israel and if you'd
like to read that joel or anybody i
think that's going to help you better
understand that christianity really is
rooted in judaism and there shouldn't be
anti-semitism in christians minds
to receive the book just call the number
800-835-6747 it's called spiritual
israel and we'll be able to send that to
anyone who calls and asks if you're
outside of north america just go to the
amazing facts website
amazingfacts.com.org
we've got
june listening in california june
welcome to the program
hello hello pastors how are you
good thank you for calling
thank you for taking my call yeah just a
quick question on exodus 4 24.
i'm just
wondering why god would want to kill
moses yeah this is a this verse usually
gets some interesting um questions
people are reading through the bible and
they go through exodus they get to
chapter four
and it uh
it makes this interesting statement
where moses is on his way to egypt and
in route it says the lord tried to slay
him
now just the very idea that god would
try to slay somebody it's can you leave
you wondering did god swing and miss
you know if god wants to slay you he's
going to slay you and basically he's
saying that
the wrath of god was rising up against
moses because moses had been called to
lead the people he'd accepted the call
he had been convicted by the holy spirit
that as the leader he needed to embrace
the covenant to abraham
he had not had his own son or at least
one of his sons circumcised
and i think maybe he had argued about
this with his wife because finally his
wife says okay
she circumcises the boy and she said
you're a bloody man maybe she thought it
was barbaric or who knows what the
discussion was but
moses had not followed through in doing
what god said and god was saying if you
continue
going down the road you're in
high-handed disobedience you're going to
be leading my covenant people and you're
not following the covenant in your own
family
so
reading between the lines most
commentators think this is what was
happening here
and i think the the verse there at least
the the idea as you mentioned passed it
if god wanted to destroy moses yeah he
would have done it but uh
the lord appeared in a threatening
manner to moses kind of like the angel
with balaam and his donkey that's right
with a raised sword maybe he could have
killed him if you wanted to
just to illustrate the importance of uh
what it is that moses had to do in being
faithful to the covenant good question
next quarter that we have is claudette
listening from new jersey claudette
welcome to the program
good evening pastor doctor for taking me
yeah emperor and pastor ross
yes my question is based on um first
corinthians 11 verse 5 and 6 and also
verse 15.
it says whatever woman that prayed or
prophesied with her head uncovered this
honor at her head for that is even all
one as she was shaven for if the woman
be not covered let her order be shorn
and then in verse 15 it says but if a
woman have long hair it is a glory to
her for her hair is given for her cup
for her covering so if she's but if a
woman has long hair she's practicing her
praying in shirt should she still be a
head covering over her over and upstairs
here
all right here's the big question and
it's a it's a valid question and this uh
whenever we get this question
we need to answer with some humility
because it's a difficult verse
the big question is was paul addressing
a custom
or was he addressing a command
there's no command
earlier in the bible that women should
not pray with or without their heads
covered i don't know if there's anything
says anything about
uh the only time it talks about covering
the head is sometimes if they were
mourning they would cover their heads
but um
so
later in the same chapter in pastor ross
you probably can find the verse that
says for we have no such custom i think
the word custom is actually used in this
passage let me give you an example
claudette when i am in um oh japan or
some places in india
pastor ross and i were in a church in
india where they get you know 18 000
people i'll take off their shoes put
them in cubby holes well it's considered
bad manners and disrespectful
for you to
walk in with your shoes
and
paul is saying that you know it was
accustomed that women as a sign of
humility that they covered their heads
was that cultural and then paul is
saying your hair is a covering
god gives women a natural covering of
hair typically more than men
um and then he later says in another
place it's a shame for men to have long
hair
so he's just saying there ought to be
this distinction
but um
you know it appears it's a custom i have
no
qualms if some if a woman says i'm
convicted i should cover my head when
i'm in church
i say praise the lord you follow the
holy spirit it certainly won't hurt
anybody i think the point also passed
today is it's emphasizing reverence in
the sanctuary yeah and again different
customs different ways of doing things
back in bible times and again also in
the middle east even today that is a
sign of reverence in our culture pastor
doug it would be a sign of of um
disrespect or or
a lack of reverence if a man walks into
a church and he leaves on his big cowboy
hat i mean you remove your hat when
you're coming to a church that's the
sign of respect so i think the context
there is we need to be reverent when we
enter in to worship and in the presence
right whatever that culture might be
yeah and paul was saying the women were
behaving in a scandalous disrespectful
way in the corinthian church and he was
addressing that
you know the verse you referred to is
also first corinthians chapter 11 verse
16 where paul says but if anyone seems
to be contentious we do not have such a
custom
nor do the churches of god so it's re
referring to a specific situation that
was taking place there yeah amen all
right thank you for your call uh we've
got tavision listening in illinois tavis
and welcome to the program
it's dayrion hey tavian welcome
there you go
um
my question is um
if i can talk correctly uh my question
is um how do you know that the holy
spirit's still working in you
if you've been a christian for years and
you've noticed that you're not as
sensitive or as passionate
about christ as you used to be
well first of all don't get discouraged
you just described what it says in
revelation chapter 2 where he says the
ephesian church had lost its first love
they were still his people there still
his church
you'll often see even in a marriage that
during the time of dating and honeymoon
there's just there's a lot of um romance
and excitement
and then you know after 10 years of
marriage
things become a little more routine
well the lord you know in our marriages
we want to keep that love alive and also
in your relationship with the lord it
doesn't mean you're not a christian
anymore
you know even mary and joseph
they took the rise of jesus when he was
a young man they lost him in jerusalem
and mary said we spent three days
sorrowing and searching for you
and if we take our eyes off jesus
sometimes we spend some time sorrowing
and searching to find him again
but i would say
seek after the lord and he'll be found
that's the promise
draw near to god and he'll draw near to
you you want to renew that
relationship that love
and the way that happens he said jesus
said do the first works
i'm sure when you first fell in love
with the lord you were pouring over his
word you're spending time in prayer you
were thinking about his presence you
were sharing it with your friends
do those things again and you'll find a
renewal in the holy spirit and the you
know your sense of god's presence
you know i'm just wanting to pass today
what book we have that might 12 steps to
revival there we go that's the one
that'll be a great blessing to anyone
wanting to have a deeper fuller
experience with jesus uh read the book
it's um we'll send it to you for free
the number is 800-835-6747
you can answer the book 12 steps for
revival we'll be happy to send it to you
also pastor you did a series not too
long ago uh called the new heart i think
it's a 10-part series
and that is available i believe on
youtube so if you want to look that up
yeah amazing facts website it's under
the amazon that's right there also on
the amazing facts website so um that'll
be a blessing
uh next quarter that we have is daniel
and he's listening from vi where is that
virginia
daniel welcome yes pastors
thank you pastors good evening yeah
calling from virginia here uh just a
question on revelation 14 7 first
angel's message uh
you know i know that um the last part of
the verse there is a direct reference to
the fourth commandment uh the sabbath
commandment i was just wondering whether
commentators have said or in general
it's understood that the first three
commandments can be found in that verse
as well fear god would be the first
commandment give glory to him by
reflecting his image the second
commandment for the hours judgment has
come
um
in other words judging between who's
taking the name the lord's name in vain
and who's not
i'm wondering if you can see in general
the the first table of the fourth
command the ten commandments there in
that verse and in in the counterpart
verse as well in revelation 15 2
where it talks about the victory of the
beast the first commandment over his
image the second commandment over his
mark the fourth commandment and over the
number of his name which would be the
third commandment i don't know if you
see that or commentators have seen that
or that's kind of a
well stretch
i i don't know that i view it all the
same way but it's interesting that
you're saying this because just moments
before the program i was thinking about
revelation 14 and how revelation 14
is sort of a condensed bible the the
last message is found in there and
you're making me think as you're
speaking about just seeing the uh the
other commandments
in this passage
um and for our friends that are
listening
the bible is written in a chiastic form
meaning that
you've kind of got like the
white bread
let's say it's whole wheat bread just
for health's sake and then in the middle
you've got the substance
and it's often in the hebrew writings
that in the middle you'll find the
climax revelation 14 is like the climax
of revelation it's all concentrated in
there
and
it sort of summarizes who is saved and
who is lost and why
so you can also find i think the law of
god talks about those who keep the
commandments of god in verse 12.
that's uh that's fascinating i
appreciate that
and give me give me some ideas yeah
first angel's message actually quotes
from the fourth commandment where it
says worship him who made the heavens
the earth the sea right so that's
actually from part of the ten
commandments yeah and i can see i you
can see
allusions to the other commandments uh
in earlier in that verse or other places
now friends we don't have time to do
another question before we finish our
first half but we've got a lot more
bible question time coming so stay tuned
we have some important announcements for
you we're going to be back and and call
in with your bible questions 800 god
says 800 god says and we'll be back
[Music]
stay tuned bible answers live will
return shortly
go into all the world and preach the
gospel to every creature
through radio television print
evangelistic events and the internet
amazing facts international is heeding
the call of jesus to go into all the
world
millions of individuals in over 150
countries have been blessed by the word
of god amazing facts has spawned new
spheres of influence in india africa
china and indonesia with each new
country come hundreds of translated
booklets study guides and video
presentations produced in each region
for the people of that region armed with
these precious truths gospel workers are
empowered to spread bright rays of light
on every path they travel
please visit reachtheworld.org
to learn more about amazing facts
international and how you can
participate in this exciting
soul-winning ministry that website again
is reachtheworld.amazingfacts.org
thank you for your support
the u.s government is drowning in debt
to the tune of 22 trillion dollars but
before you wag your finger at the
government spending the federal reserve
says the average american household
carries over a hundred and thirty seven
thousand dollars in debt well it was
never god's plan that we live with the
burden of debt proverbs 22 7 warns us
the rich rules over the poor and the
borrower is servant to the lender living
with debt is a stressful burden that
actually hurts your relationship with
god
in my new pocketbook deliverance from
debt i outline the bible principles on
how to properly manage your money with
some practical suggestions and how you
can get out and stay out of debt
if you or someone you love is drowning
in debt
order a copy of deliverance from debt
today it can be a lifesaver to keep you
from going under please call
800-538-7200
or visit afbookstore.com
you're listening to bible answers live
where every question answered provides a
clearer picture of god and his plan to
save you so what are you waiting for get
practical answers about the good book
for a better life today
[Music]
if you have a question about the bible
or living the christian life call us now
at 800 god says that's
answers 800-463-7297
welcome back listening friends to bible
answers live and if you're tuning in for
the first time this is a live
international interactive bible study
and we invite people around the country
and other parts of the world
call in with your bible questions we'll
do our best to give you
a brief answer sometimes we can't give a
big comprehensive answer to some of the
questions but we try to take as many
questions as we can and make them
understandable so that we can apply the
word of god to our lives my name is doug
batchelor my name is john ross and we've
got bronwyn listening and ready with
this question bronwyn from tennessee
welcome to the program
hello good evening evening
and your question
is if god knows the beginning to the end
why did he create satan
that's a good question
um
sometimes the lord allows things even
though he knows that it's going to cause
problems
he made all of his creatures free
and he even made a beautiful angel named
lucifer very powerful angel made him
free that means he's free to love god to
worship god to make choices
lucifer chose
to not love god and to love himself more
and all of the sin in the universe has
come from people making that choice
so
before now how old are you do you mind
my asking
i'll be 21 in october so i'm 20. you're
20. okay you sounded younger forgive me
um
when you're when your parents decided to
have you assuming it was a free choice
did they get any kind of written
guarantee
that you would always be cooperative and
a good child and obedient
no
but they took a risk because they wanted
to love you and wanted love
and that
you might make other choices right
yes sir
so god made his creatures and gave them
freedom to choose
knowing there was a risk and he knew
what lucifer would do
and it's demonstrating to the whole
universe
what the problem of sin is and uh it'll
never happen again
so but you know we have a dvd
that covers this you can probably watch
for free online i think we have new
cosmic conflict magazine is out that's
right we've got several flags actually
it's just coming now it's not printed
yet it's not yet well we do have the
cosmic conflict dvd and um bronwyn or
anyone listening or watching you can
just simply go to the amazing facts
website and you'll be able to view that
that dvd there or i think it's also
available on youtube we also have a
study guide that's called did god create
a devil and we'll be happy to send that
to anyone who calls and asks the number
is
800-835-6747 and asks for the book it's
called the god create a devil and we'll
send it to anyone who calls and asks
jose is listening in puerto rico jose
welcome to the program
hello welcome can you hear me we can
thanks for calling
ah
sure my question is uh if christ's
suffering was a byproduct of our sins
or a requirement for our salvation
um i'm looking for the tabernacle and
the tabernacle of course is the
representation of jesus but in the
tabernacle the
the sacrificial lamb
does not have pass for a tribulation
like a suffering of christ
right well of course keep in mind that
the sacrificial system with lambs with
symbolic clearly a lamb cannot think and
experience the anguish of a human of
betrayal and those different things
in fact the the priests kind of went out
of the way to make the sacrifice of the
lamb as painless and quick as possible
because it all symbolized christ and his
sacrifice but the sacrifice of christ
the hardest part was not actually the
death it was the suffering the
separation from god in the death that he
experienced that's like when jonah went
into the belly of the whale for three
days and three nights jesus
when god withdrew his protection there
in the garden of gethsemane he went
through incredible suffering and turmoil
where he was weeping in the garden
perspiring blood
so
the lamb i wouldn't try and make too
strong a comparison because the lamb was
simply a symbol
a symbol of jesus and of course the
wages of sin is death and that's what
was emphasized
but along with the wages of sin there is
suffering
we know that everyone at the end will be
rewarded according to their works so
that's both for the righteous and the
unrighteous there are there are degrees
of judgment degrees of punishment for
the wicked christ suffered for the sins
of the whole world the bible tells us
all right thank you fred in oregon fred
welcome to the program
thank you much thanks for taking my call
my question uh matthew 25 verse nine
were the five foolish asked the five
wise for some of their oil and they said
no that they had to go
to those that sell to buy their own
now i know in revelation 13 if you have
you can't buy or sell unless you have
the mark so is this an indication that
these five
foolish have the mark
you know i i think that the parable of
the ten virgins is not just talking
about
um the mark of the beast and the seal of
god i think it's talking about professed
christians
and it not only applies to the last days
because jesus does make matthew 25 is on
the heels of the signs of his second
coming but i think in every age
god has had his people that some that
had a knowing relationship they had the
holy spirit they had a reserve
and those who were careless
and they were not watching and praying
they were not ready they they had not
fortified their faith for times of trial
and darkness
and or they lost their patience you know
the bible talks about he that endures to
the end will be saved
certainly in the last days those that
are lost the five foolish virgins they
would be
getting the mark of the beast and the
five
who have it uh have the oil they're
gonna have the seal of god they'll be
saved
but um
i don't know if i'm answering what
you're asking
it's
it's just been something that that i've
wondered about because we obviously we
in the last days are not able to can't
buy ourselves
can't buy or sell
yeah i just didn't know with these
well with the 10 virgins
yeah when the wise versions pardon me
for jumping in but when the wise virgins
tell the foolish you must buy for
yourself
we cannot take someone else's experience
from them we must have our own
experience they said you've got to have
it for yourself
and they waited too long to have that
personal experience or have that filling
with the holy spirit
and
you know that that applies it's a truth
in every time
uh i don't think it's talking so much
about buying and selling where is it in
revelation chapter 3 where jesus has
says to the church of laodicea you know
buy of me gold tried in the fire
and then isaiah says oh everyone that
there's by without money without price
and so when it says buy it doesn't
always mean
you know going to the market and pulling
out your credit card
by means go obtain
and these are all professed followers of
christ right describes them as
waiting for the bridegroom divergence
that's right they have a pure faith they
have the lamp which represents the word
of god so even with amongst those who
profess to be waiting for the coming of
jesus you've got the wise and you've got
the foolish now the foolish will
eventually get the mark of the beast but
at that time where they're all together
they're all professing to follow christ
so it's sort of a warning a wake-up call
for the church i think yeah and they're
all waiting for the bridegroom to come
that's right
all right thank you for your call we've
got john listening in um
any nebraska remember all my states here
nebraska johnny nebraska welcome
that's right thank you for taking my
call appreciate it watch you guys all
the time
thank you john
and your question
well it's kind of a mixed up question
but i'll try to get it out the way i
want to talk to your man beforehand
if um jesus said if you love staff to a
woman you have committed adultery in
your heart excuse me uh if if a man is
watching porn all the time and he's
lusting after the woman he's committing
adultery in his heart
if a wife gets a divorce can she remarry
that'd be my question i guess okay that
i what you said makes sense um first of
all i would not compare
uh a man or a woman who's having a
struggle with pornography
as being the same thing
as committing an actual affair
you know in most laws
most countries
thinking about murdering someone is
definitely not the same thing as
murdering somebody
and so
when a person is committing adultery in
their heart there's definitely sin in
the heart jesus says that there's a sin
of adultery in the heart but it's not
the same as committing the act of
adultery and i think that's so important
to understand because i've met
men and women before that said well i'm
thinking about it i may as well do it
there's a big difference between the two
and i've
i've talked to women before and they
said you know my husband i caught him
viewing pornography and so that's
adultery and so i'm going to divorce him
i also think that's a mistake i don't
think this is what jesus is talking
about
now it is certainly a sin
if a woman
[Music]
divorces a man and she does not have
biblical grounds or if a man divorces
his wife christ said they don't really
have a right to remarry
um and i know i'll probably get letters
on this uh that you know people are
going to say well it's the same thing
i actually went into depth
in my book on marriage divorce and
remarriage i talk about this because a
lot of people have asked about it
pornography is an epidemic today
and there's a lot of people that are
wondering well
since my spouse has had a problem with
this
um is that grounds for divorce
it becomes a really slippery slope when
you say yes because
some people describe pornography as the
daytime soap operas
and you know two people obviously
committing adultery and it goes from
there all the way to what they call hard
porn
and so
where do you draw the line if you start
saying thinking it is the same as doing
it then
you know you can drive by a billboard
with a girl in a bathing suit and say
now i can file for divorce
and so you've got to be very careful i
hope that makes sense to everybody and
of course i think you're emphasizing the
fact pastor nick that it's still sin
jesus makes it very clear something that
needs to be repented of and if somebody
continues down those paths
they are going to eventually harden
their heart against the prompting of the
holy spirit and the attitude often leads
to the action exactly yeah exactly but
it's not necessarily the same thing
right so we need to be aware of that
good question thank you for calling next
quarter that we have is guy listening
from california guy welcome to the
program
hello thank you for taking my call
yes
and your question okay so my question is
uh regarding
uh genesis 31 verse 19
uh and it says in that verse that laban
had gone to see to the cutting of the
wool of his sheep so rachel secretly
took the images of the gods of her
father's house
so why did rachel steal
images or gods of laban
or is there some kind of uh secret
uh power to these gods or these idols i
mean were they gonna tell him
or tell tell uh
yeah were they gonna tell him where
rachel and um
yeah
the the word gods there they they used
to have idols that were like it was a
god
and it was something of like a property
deed
you'll read later where well first of
all i i highly recommend that nobody has
a god that can be stolen
because if your god can be packed in
someone's camel back and written off
with you've got a pretty small god
so that always strikes me as funny that
laven comes says you stole my gods
and she she put him in the saddle bag
and sat on them
sitting on his god
so
most commentators that i've seen pastor
ross you may have seen something
different in this they say that
because
the daughters said to jacob our father
has taken our dowry he hasn't given you
know everything that we should have
gotten as a dowry he's taken from us he
spent it and the girls wanting to have
something of value took or at least
rachel took these gods these idols which
were like property deeds
and
they had some value attached to him
there was some monetary value attached
to it i don't think it's also clear that
um you know the family rachel's family
laban and like even though they claimed
to worship the true god
the customs of those living around them
had probably crept into their
understanding for that reason was
important that god was to take abraham
and his descendants out from the land of
her so there was kind of a little bit of
a mix of idolatry maybe that was also
part of the reason here she's leaving
home she wants to take something maybe
to remind her of they were little idols
yeah but i don't know that they
worshipped them but they they did have
little idols i think that were sort of
carved out of stone or whatever it is
and they had value maybe they could be
sold for something yeah all right
interesting good question all right
we've got jared listening from missouri
jared welcome to the program
uh hello thank you
yes thank you jared your question
uh my question is if we're supposed to
judge the evil angels
doesn't that mean we were predestined to
fall into temptation at the
garden of eden since we had to know good
and evil at the the tree of good and
evil
i'm not sure i understand the the
rationale of your question you know the
bible does this do you not know that you
will judge angels i agree with that
so you're saying that that somehow is
connected with predestination
yeah because we had
to uh to know evil we had to eat the
fruit of good and evil to judge right
yeah well i i think let me let's just
back up and talk about what the verse is
saying i think paul is telling us that
when he says no you're not that you will
judge angels he's talking i think that's
first corinthians seven he's he's saying
you know you need to be able to judge in
the smallest matters don't you know you
can even judge angels
well obviously christians are not going
to decide if angels are saved or lost
when we get to heaven the veil is pulled
aside we're going to not only see our
guardian angels we probably are going to
see the angels that were are
our
menaces
uh during our lives or our adversaries
that satan had appointed to tempt us and
we're going to say yes this angel was
the one that you know was leading me
into sin and uh you know he deserves his
punishment
so we'll be affirming the judgments of
god uh i think in that
but um
i don't know why predestination would
need to fit into that scenario in other
words can you judge without knowing evil
between good and evil well i think you
can yeah i mean to judge is to discern
and even adam and eve in the garden of
eden it was never god's purpose or
desire that they eat from the tree of
the knowledge of good and evil
but they could choose and they could
discern and say no we don't want to eat
of that we do want to eat of this so it
doesn't necessarily mean that you have
to you know
partake of evil to know that it's bad
right
we do have a book that talks about
predestination and it's called can a
save man choose to be lost if you'd like
to receive that the number to call is
800-835-6747 you can ask for the book
can a saved man choose to be lost we'll
be happy to send it to anyone in north
america
next quarter that we have connor
listening from colorado connor welcome
to the program thanks for your patience
yep thank you how are you guys doing
great
alrighty so
um i've been keeping the original
sabbath for a while now
and i had some friends and family that
just
kind of argued with the importance of
course in a friendly way and i just
wanted to know what the importance was
of keeping the original sabbath
well when you say the original sabbath
um you know the bible tells us that god
created the world in six days
that he blessed the seventh day
uh that was reiterated for the children
of israel when he saved them he said
remember now god want to say remember if
something didn't prior exist
they had forgotten it living among the
egyptians he said remember the i've set
aside a day for
spiritual and physical rest to worship
god and god blessed that day god rested
that day he says i've blessed a
particular day the seventh day and i
want you to remember the seventh day and
it says it three times there he blessed
the seventh day he sanctified the
seventh day and he asked us to remember
that
well over time during
the
time of the roman era there was a lot of
compromise and they gradually switched
from the seventh day to the first day
and you can read about that during the
time of constantine he's the one who
published the edict of milan
i would say that if it's one of the ten
commandments how important is one of the
ten commandments
and you know some will argue it doesn't
matter what day it is as long as it's a
seventh day but god doesn't say keep a
seventh day he says keep the seventh
today it's a particular day god didn't
say for everybody to pick their own day
think about the uh
the chaos that would be in the christian
church if everyone picks their own day
of worship and there's no corporate
worship
so um you know the sabbath
can be traced all the way back to adam
and eve
they kept it in the old testament
the apostles kept it jesus kept it and
it says in isaiah we're going to keep it
in heaven so
that's a quick summary it's still
important we have a lesson on that that
has all these we do it's called the last
day of history and we'll be happy to
send this to anyone who calls and asks
the number is 800-835-6747
as for the amazing facts study guide
it's called the last day in history we
also have a website called
sabbathtruth.com that's filled with
great bible studies this video all on
the subject of the bible sabbath and
you'll enjoy taking a look at that
we've got bruce listening from north
carolina bruce welcome to the program
hello pastors
hi thank you for calling
i would like to um for you to explain
the time prophecy in daniel 12.
all right now for our friends that are
listening
last chapter of daniel daniel chapter
12. brings about a summary of the
prophecies mentioned earlier in the book
daniel outlines
the history of god's people and the
battle they're going to have with good
and evil and even highlights the beast
power
in daniel chapter 7 8
and so when you get to chapter 12 he
backs up and he reviews those time
periods one time is 1260 years
then there's another time that is 1290
years and there's 1335 years
and you know i said a minute ago we try
to summarize our questions in two or
three minutes it's hard to do that with
this question
but those three time prophecies you can
see that let's start with the 1260.
is mentioned several times in the bible
1260 in the jewish year that's
1260 days
that is three and a half years jesus
taught for three and a half years the
famine of elijah three and a half years
um esther's process to choose esther
began three and a half years after this
feast or
after the
um book begins up to the feast
um
and in daniel it talks about a time at
times in the dividing of a time
a time was a year a times was a pair or
a couple of years it's two and one is
three and a dividing a half
42 months is in revelation 42 months 30
days the jewish month 1260 days you've
got that time period talks about a time
of apostasy resistance persecution
happens several times in the bible and
so um that is one of the principal times
that's repeated in revelation daniel
adds the time 1290 and 1335 because he
gives a starting point in christian
history
when um
yeah clovis the king of the franks the
holy roman empire basically was
inaugurated
and yeah the date for that 508
and what's significant about that date
is
clovis who was uh leader of the franks
was in opposition at first to the roman
power to the papacy but when he
converted to christianity he was a pagan
when he converted to christianity that
really opened up the whole area known
today as of as france
to become supportive of the papal power
yeah so 508 is considered the starting
date for that 1290 and the 1335 starting
at that same date in 508 brings you up
to 1843 when there was a great revival
that was taking place in north america
and other places around the world
and they were discovering the prophecies
of daniel in particular the 2300 days of
daniel 8 14. so just a really
interesting study when you look at these
different time periods you know pastor
we probably i don't think we have a book
specifically on daniel 12 but maybe
that's something we need the right one
yeah as you're talking about this
question we need to write something yeah
absolutely all right well thanks for
your cole we've got uh let's see jim
listening in canada jim welcome to the
program
uh thank you very much uh very much for
uh having me on uh and uh i do like to
say you guys are my favorite pastors on
tv well thank you for joining the
seventh day a few years ago and uh and
it's a blessing well bless your heart my
question is
what my question is is the commandment
of thou shalt not kill
and
and i noticed that a lot of
pastors
are saying thou shalt not murder now
to me that's changing it and god said
not to change it
so and i've noticed like when i watched
that movie hacksaw
dobbs could not be swayed
and he did not kill
and he performed a to me a super miracle
he saved all those people on that ridge
yeah it was remarkable you know well let
me talk about that yeah he he refused to
pick up a gun
and he was not going to kill he he was a
fellow human and of course jesus tells
us to overcome evil with a good uh by
the way i knew desmond doss and he's
just a wonderful man
his uh his wife
was
her family wasn't a church i pastored so
i'd see him on a regular basis he'd come
up to visit her family
anyway
jesus actually uses the word and you
might look this up pastor ross i think
it's in mark chapter 10 when jesus is
quoting the ten commandments to the rich
young ruler and he quotes that
commandment he specifically says thou
shalt not murder now there is a
difference between murder and killing
and i think you'll agree jim that you
know if you step on a weed and you kill
it you're not going to be called a
murderer and that's not breaking that
commandment thou shall not kill or if a
mosquito is biting you and you swat it
to put it out of its misery
you've technically killed the mosquito
but you've not broken the commandment
thou shall not kill
that commandment and then why would god
tell moses
thou shalt not kill
and then tell moses to execute and stone
certain people that had broken other
commandments
the verse referring to matthew 19 18
which jesus says thou shalt not murder
and he uses the word murder
murder is defined as a taking of
innocent life
and human life in particular
so um
i i do think that we've got to be
careful not to think of thou shalt not
kill in the broad sense of killing
anything
it's really talking about taking of
innocent human life if a person is
defending their family and some crazed
murderer comes into their home and in
the process of defending their family
they have to kill the perpetrator
they are not ever tried by any people as
a killer
because they've not committed murder
it's just self-defense or if somebody
you know an accident occurs yeah and
accidentally somebody gets killed and
it's just an accident you're not you
don't hold that person accountable for
murder in fact there's even a story in
the bible and it gives the example if
you're swinging an axe and the axe head
comes off and kills somebody uh you know
you're not held liable for murder you go
to a city of refuge and then they find
that it was an accident
yeah and even the laws today laws about
manslaughter it's talking about
unintentional you've got premeditated
murder and so forth so yeah i think it's
closer to say thou shalt not murder even
though i know the king james and some
versions say thou shalt not kill
i would i would respect that we do have
our lesson we started out with saying
written in stone talks more about that
law now pastor ross for our friends that
are listening or watching right now
we we sort of sign off in stages we want
to say goodbye to our friends that are
listening on satellite radio but the
rest of you don't go anywhere because
just a moment we're going to come back
we're going to take some rapid fire
bible questions that you have sent in
via email god bless to the rest
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast we hope you understand your
bible even better than before
bible answers live is produced by
amazing facts international a
faith-based ministry located in granite
bay california
[Music]
hello friends welcome back we have about
two and a half minutes past the deck to
answer some of the email questions that
have come into the program if you'd like
to send us an email question the email
address is bal questions at
amazingfacts.org
all right question number one britney is
asking what did jesus mean when he
called the pharisees a brood of vipers
yeah and i think that um even john the
baptist uses that term well in the bible
vipers are considered snakes they're
considered synonymous in many places
with the devil whereas at revelation
chapter 12 is at least one place where
it calls
that old serpent the dragon satan
and so it calls him the devil satan
dragon serpent
and so when you say a brood of vipers
he's basically saying
you're a bunch of
demon-led individuals which is you know
you think about a snake pit
and they would get together and they
would connive and talk about how to you
know persecute god's prophets and and so
jesus and
they let a lot of people stray he said
you rob with those houses so it was not
a compliment okay we have another
question jackie is asking do we really
have to pray for those who are wicked
well you know jesus says love your
enemies and we should be thankful that
while we were yet sinners christ died
for us so even in our lostness in our
wickedness
a wickedness would be you know sort of
like intentional disobedience
god is merciful to us and i think we
know there are stories in the bible of
people who are wicked i think of
manasseh was probably the best example
you know sacrifices children in the fire
killed isaiah the prophet
wicked man he went through a dramatic
conversion
so yes even wicked people can be reached
by the power of god we also have the
conversion of nebuchadnezzar king of
babylon yeah all right another question
that we have isabel wants to know how
can she be bold for jesus but in a
subtle way because she's timid
well you can of course be bold in your
prayers
and uh the lord can make even a timid
person bold at the right time
uh you know talks about the righteous or
as bold as a lion line
so
i think you know as you just pray for
opportunity to speak up
you can be bold with the words that you
speak and they don't have to be loud
you can say something profound
and they'll get everyone's attention
okay well pastor doug we want to remind
our friends who are listening if you
have a bible question and you'd like to
submit it to the program just email bal
questions at
amazingfacts.org and we will try to
answer as many questions as we can
before we run out of time and you hear
music in the background so we want to
thank you for joining us and next week
we look forward to meeting you again for
another program of bible anchor live
bible answers live honest and accurate
answers to your bible questions
[Music]